President Trump is back at the White
House after a more than week-long
vacation he and his advisors are pushing
back against the idea that a recession
could be coming and they're also
watching China's response to protesters
in Hong Kong chip reads at the White
House chip the president is trying to
give Beijing some advice indeed he is
he's suggesting that the Chinese
government handle those protesters in
Hong Kong carefully as for the economy
he said he's ready for anything but at
the same time he said he does not expect
a recession I think it would be very
hard to deal if they do violence sending
a signal to Chinese President Xi Jinping
on Sunday President Trump warned that
government retaliation against
protesters in Hong Kong could threaten a
potential trade deal with the u.s.
President Xi obviously has this in mind
because he probably would have acted
faster even so the president suggested
he might not pull back on tariffs
against China any time soon I'm just the
u.s. economy has been a bright spot for
Donald Trump's presidency he's overseen
a flourishing job market with a nearly
50-year lower unemployment rate and a
generally strong stock market but last
week the Dow plunged 800 points in one
day the biggest single-day drop of the
year as investors forecast concerns with
the global economy the White House is
not working to project calm I sure don't
see her accession but even mr. Trump
conceded his trade war with China is
affecting the markets if I wanted to
make a bad deal and settle on China the
market would go up last week mr. Trump
announced a delay on some tariffs
against China as studies show the
tariffs would have cost Americans an
average of 270 dollars a year potential
impacts mr. Trump's advisors are
brushing off tariffs are working they're
important part of the strategy to bring
the Chinese to the negotiating table
White House chief economic advisor Larry
Kudlow said that if talks with the
Chinese go well over the next 10 days
then Chinese officials will come here to
the United States to continue those
talks Tony all right chip thank you very
much